So you are here for the rest of the white race.
For very
low. Over forty five
years came to
the neighborhood in seventy
seventy two. So how long would that
be great.
Yeah yeah.
Every
year I grew up actually born in Brooklyn
by my family moved to Long Island when I
was five or six and so I grew up on Long Island
in Nassau County.
And then when I after I graduated from
college and I got married
I decided my husband I decided to move to Brooklyn back to Brooklyn. We had
heard about Park Slope from cousins who were living here and I
think there was also at the time we were trying to figure out where we
wanted to live and there was a New
York magazine had just started publishing and they had an issue on Park Slope.
So
I happened to read that and it sounded so appealing because of the old architecture
and
the and it has seemed like a nice quality of
life place to live so we decided to move here somewhere.
We moved when we first got here. We live our
heart
black presidents tree for and we paid I think
one hundred fifty dollars a month for rent over the forty
five years or so that I've been here I've moved pervasively farther away from
the park because the rents kept going up and the farther away from the park. There's a
cheaper
was so. But now I want to have and I'm
back to close the park again because I well I bought this about twenty years ago.
So if the prices weren't too bad at times. I would I mean it seemed
very high at the time but I paid for the
have but as it turns out the the real estate values
are so crazy here that it's just gone for the skyrocket.
So I'm happy that I have my place I could buy it if
I didn't weren't living here.
It's one of those things I went through for this from other people. Yeah
yeah right. And I wouldn't be able to afford it.
So I must've moved about seven or eight times
from the neighborhood I moved from between eight and a park five then I see my next places
between seven and eight and then between six and seven and I live on Sixth Avenue here for
a
few a couple for seven years
and then between fifty six and.
Now as I said now I'm back to get closer to the Parkers was just
a lucky
break
close to starting.
Just say that's a good question let me say I mean I
guess it seemed well the way
the neighborhood has evolved would she probably know about is the
area when
I met with the closer I looked the
part we wore the fancier the buildings
and the more
elegant. That's the farther away from the park I got when I
was six Avenue between fourth and fifth
Street for twenty years. There was. A lot of actually
drug dealing going
on in my in my environment. You
know on the corners and the shops on the corners a
little small shops and it was it was
very kind
of scary sometimes but you know there was so much.
I guess it was a lot of people a lot of activism and people kind of
pressuring the
police department kept getting more and more involved
and it was all the crime kind of cleaned up but as
the years went
on but there was I you know I remember experiencing that being a
little nervous and then deciding that I live here anyway so that that that I had to
just you know how
to
ice kind of.
From a distance I would see one of the one of the shots.
I think one day I
had a flat tire and I was waiting for
the AAA to come and. Change my
tire and I noticed that this shop had hardly
any products in it it had very few cigarettes and very
few candy bars it was happened to me but a lot of people kept pulling up
in front and getting out and going in and then coming out of bed to
something and I mean I never you know I never asked I never got
myself involved in that. But
I figured it out you know some I was to tell somebody about it they said yes
probably they were
buying drugs and that was the
dealer and it was kind of unnerving. But when me.
And I heard. Well
no it didn't impact on me personally nobody ever approached me
and did anything she needed was
scary and.
And I love to I just love the neighborhood I love the the buildings I love the architecture
I love the friends I made I love the community and that's one of the things actually that I
wanted
to talk about I don't know you really get to this
but one of the things that was so remarkable about this neighborhood when
I moved in and I was young and I had two little
kids and. And they didn't have much
money and there was a lot
of collective
cooperative things happening here so for example there was something called
the babysitting
pool and I and some neighbor asked me if I
had joined it and I had never heard of it so
I found out how to join it and I I joined it and it was really it was an incredible
thing that was forty five years ago my kids were you know very
young. And with what it was Have you heard anything about this
is this OK.
You know people with children would join this
group and you would your name and your address and your phone number would
be listed and I happened
to have someone had given custody of the old one that I of when
I was in the event that was her old
copy and so there were probably maybe
maybe a hundred families on the
list. And. What would happen is we
would call each
other and if we wanted to go out one night we would
get another parent to come and stay with our
kids and we pay them and little pieces of paper like tickets when
you joined you got a certain number of half
hour. Tickets are cheaper. Right because I'm so if
you went after three hours you would you would. Three
Take. I guess six tickets to the person who
you who sat for you and then
you
would and then you would get to someone else and then you would you know
they could use the tickets that you paid down to get somebody to babysit for them and I
and I would babysit for someone else and they would pay me a
ticket seller. Yes you did and but if you look at
the case. You deal with
that right. And so and you could arrange it I mean you would you know there'd be people that you would
just you know get used to you kind of got to know certain people so there were probably ten families that
I use because they live near me or I like them
whatever. And so we would exchange and it was it was a great way of getting to know people in
the neighborhood and I remained friends with a lot of these people all of these years.
Yeah I mean our children are gone. I've moved away but you know but they
kind of knew each other and they went to school
together over the years and. So it was really a
very interesting kind of collective experience and
now this the interesting thing is that we're now
starting a new group and
we've started this new group in Park Slope which is.
It's kind of it's called the good neighbors the Park Slope. You know if
you've heard of that but anyway it's an aging in place organization where
we're trying to we created sort of
a
network of people who join this
organization and we are doing activities
together and going places there and sharing experiences
and
expanding who we know in the neighborhood
now and our goal. Probably in the future when
we have are less able to. Get around is to
have to help each other to somebody will come and shop for you if you need it or you'll go
with someone to the doctor if they needed and so our goal is to
be supportive to each other and it's called an aging in place
of organization so we can get older here. So
this neighborhood has sort
of well you know ran a lot of the same people who are
in this babysitting for all are now in the good neighbors of Park Slope.
Yeah
yeah. And they're joining the neighborhood as the organization
and I see their name on the list of who the members
are and so I can now go to a group and there they
are so it's really quite interesting neighborhood and I think it has to
do with the neighborhood. It has to do with people living here so long and feeling
so connected to it
and just let me in I mean but people have to weigh in
our kids you know the way but but the parents are still here.
It's interesting to
know
some of them some of them some of them I lost touch with but then I
would run into them at some point or maybe at an event and say Oh I
DO YOU REMEMBER ME. You know and I reintroduce ourselves
and it's which
is depend you know who can remain friends you know friends
with hundreds of people over the years but
yet you're
you're you're.
Well it was one. That was one source of getting to know people.
This was there were other things
that we did as we got to know each other we
created a date here. Group.
So we had a large part of
daycare center that we called ourselves at that time I think they are into
some larger
daycare collective. We got a space at the
time
I think the space changed over the years my kids grew it so I started using it
but they did move to other spaces but they we had a space. It was a church
basement on presidents tree and it was quite amazing there were
probably a hundred. I don't remember how many
members we had but all the parents would help
out take turns watching the kids doing
activities and we think we we collected money so we had some part time
teachers already.
But we really did it on a really low budget but it was a very interesting
period for the for the kids at the daycare. Then we
started like
a
school parent cooperate in school
that my kids were in for a few years and all you actually had members of these
various the day here at the school were people that I had
met and that is that to me people people who
wanted to do things with other
people terms of developing organizations.
Yes Yes
And that was an important
source of life.
Right
and it's very I think I don't know if other communities are like
that
but this one definitely is and it was such a terrific thing for
him to hear. I mean that's a great idea but it was my kids to grow up here but for me to live here
in my
life.
Not if I can help it I really don't want to.
Well there's no place else in real I'd rather live. I don't particularly
like warm tropical places. So it's
not like people sometimes want to go. That doesn't appeal to me.
I love the home
I decorated.
I mean as long as I'm healthy enough I suppose I
could manage. So I would have
to live someplace else but if I had a choice I would
not change.
Yet
I
do three times a week with a group of
friends and we take a walk around early in
the morning. And I like to you know
volunteer in part of
the
area cordoned off or.
I'm
in the place and I really like that and I value a lot of it is
here that I think are very
valuable like the Brooklyn Museum.
The
Park.
But
I would be interested.
If other people have you heard the same things from other people just like
that
people have talked about Am I the first one to bring this
year
here
but.
I
was thinking that my friend who I met in this way could share the
same thing but they were going to come. So
I least going with this piece
of
heritage collecting data.